click on books Emily Bingham is author
of more Daqi an early American family
she spoke about it recently at the
southern festival of books for 45
minutes any further ado I want to
introduce you to Emily Bingham I'm
looking forward to hearing you too Thank
You Annette and thank you to excuse me
the festival for having me this is
really a very impressive event I'm
really excited to see it I wish
Louisville had something like it what
you're seeing right here and we've had
slight technical difficulties so bear
with me a little but what you're seeing
here on the screen is an image of a
historic home in Raleigh North Carolina
it's known as the more turkey house it
is open to the public and it was built
and lived in by one member of the family
who doesn't play a big part in what I'll
be talking about today but I've used it
as sort of a frame for the slide show
what I'll be doing today is giving you a
bit of context for the book how I came
to it how this family that I've written
about came to the south because that is
where they lived and then I'll delve
into one episode in this in the story
which is this sort of sprawling three
generational saga one episode involving
a quite intense conflict between a
parent and a child there'll be some
slides throughout and again you know
this is I'm writing about a period in
which images were not as prolific and as
they are today so you'll see some
repetition there and then at the end
there'll be time for some questions what
I've written is is what I like to think
of as a saga it's it's three generations
of a Jewish family and it begins in the
time of the American Revolution at the
found
of the nation and it follows this family
as they established their place and
found their identity through the period
of the Civil War it's not a novel but
I'm very flattered by Annette's
estimation that it reads like one and it
was based entirely on the records that
this family left behind and I'm talking
about thousands and thousands of
documents they are now in repositories
and they are there for you and others to
see as well the beauty of these sources
though is their ability to transport us
through time into the emotional lives of
a family in ways that I think illuminate
both our own families and our own lives
as well as the past and it's just not
very often that we can see this closely
into a family's experience they they
wrote everything down
they were very self aware and that was
just an amazing opportunity for me the
more turkeys were pioneers struggling to
match ambitions to accomplishments in
what was for them a new region the South
it is inescapably therefore a Jewish
story but their journey was also I think
quintessentially American for really
everyone after Yorktown
confronted the issue of how they fit
into this untried and we sometimes
forget unstable experiment in freedom
the United States of America now you'll
hear me I need to say a word about
pronunciation because you will hear me
call them more Turkey and I want to
reassure you don't worry I do know
better of course their name should be
pronounced Mordecai my reason for
persisting in this irritation to many of
my listeners is that this is how the
family called themselves and I want to
be both historically accurate and also
follow the rules of etiquette and one of
the first
I learned from my mother was that you
call people the way they wish to be
called now not everybody in the family
actually followed this pronunciation
though almost all of them did and there
is a little funny story about this there
was an Ellen Moir Turkey she grew up in
the house that you see there in Raleigh
but she married a cousin and this cousin
had grown up in Mobile Alabama and his
family had apparently reverted to the
common pronunciation and so therefore on
her wedding day she became Ellen
Mordecai Mordecai I had no idea what I
was getting into when I began reading
these papers as a graduate student in
1990 but 2004 will mark 350 years of the
Jewish presence in North America and
actually this is going going to involve
a broad celebration so be on the lookout
and contrary to popular belief or
impression in places like New York or LA
or major urban centers like that the
South has played an important part in
that story and especially in the early
stages of that story and while I was
drawn into this story by the strong
characters and vibrant minds and
dramatic events that made reading about
the more turkeys like reading the fodder
for a great sprawling George Elliot or
Jane Austen production it turns out that
I had also come upon something quite
unusual
no single Jewish family has left such
extensive and really intimate papers for
this first century of American history
so well that is not really where I
thought I was getting into that is what
I found I had on my hands and that is
another I think great gift that that the
project has has given now those papers
among other things tell how it felt to
be Jewish at the birth of a nation how
to find a pate how how they found a
patriotic voice and face the challenges
of amelia in which being jewish was just
one aspect of whom one could be the
papers also tell what it was like to
live in the
south in a period when evangelical
Christianity in the form of the Second
Great Awakening was revolutionising
individual lives and social history
through it all the more turkeys
accomplished a great deal when the
Republic was young one daughter in the
family inspired a best-selling British
author to penned the first novel delving
into the psychological aspects of
anti-semitism and this woman Rachel sort
of lies at the center of the book and
she you know really made a contribution
to literary history her brother Moses
more Turkey and he's the one who built
the house that that you saw at the
beginning was the first Jew admitted to
the North Carolina bar and he was spoken
of as a candidate for the state Supreme
Court before early death cut off his
career yet another brother George
Washington more Turkey the naming in
this family interesting goes
interestingly goes from quite biblical
Jewish names to to non Jewish names and
in this case as you can see a very
patriotic name George Washington
Mordecai became a bank and railroad
president and he married into one of
North Carolina's wealthiest clans a
third brother Alfred was the
highest-ranking Jew in the United States
Army at the opening of the Civil War and
his story is one that kind of frames the
end of the book and is quite dramatic as
well you see him here with George
McClellan they were actually visiting
the Crimea studying during that war
studying the munitions that were used
there there's a long way to go in 1855
women were central to articulating the
more Tukey's values their sense of
themselves as a family that was chosen
and not merely because they were Jewish
the more Turkey women worked to directly
with men to fulfill the family's
covenant which promised that the highest
levels of personal virtue intellectual
cultivation and family unity with talk
together with hard work would secure the
respect as citizens in this new nation
these women who were assertive were
assertive far beyond what one might
expect even as they deferred to fathers
brothers and husbands but they did not
always defer people often ask why I
wrote this book as you may have guessed
I'm not Jewish it began for me with my
interest in intellectual women of the
past and there are plenty of these in
the more turkey family I sort of thought
of myself as one and wondered what it
was like at a time when there were so
many more handicaps on women's
intellectual abilities to follow their
intellectual desires but the morning
Keys have given me a lot more than a
chance to follow that original pursuit
and even more than to delve into an area
of history that has taught me a great
deal which is about Jewish history and
Jewish American history they've given me
the chance and I hope they give others
to watch and analyze a family in
formation and I was at that point just
about to begin my own family's formation
I was getting engaged married and having
children and as I moved from that single
sort of ambitious graduate student to
scholar wife and mother of two and soon
three children I studied these
intelligent and spirited more turkeys
men and women managing their identities
and seeking to make their mark of all
the lessons I took from the more turkeys
whom I now know probably better than my
own kin the most fundamental was the
children shaped parents as much as
parents shaped
children think of the parenting
magazines and all the advice books in
the bookstores thank you to our great
publishing industry and you'll notice
how our culture feeds a fantasy a
fantasy that actually took root among
the middle classes of more turkeys era
this late 18th early 19th century a
fantasy that that that that relationship
is sort of unidirectional in one way the
parents are the ones that shape children
right
the episode that I'll be telling you
about today makes clear I think how
mistaken this is but how did the
mortgagees get to the south in the first
place
Jacob and Judy mordake the family's
patriarch and matriarch grew up in
colonial America a society for Jews that
has been called the freest in the world
at that time it was also a tiny
community numbering perhaps 2,000 Jacob
born in Philadelphia in 7 1762 lost his
father during the American Revolution
his mother who is a convert to Judaism
remarried and Jacob accepted a job from
his stepfather who had a business in
Richmond Virginia by chance while
visiting home in 1783 this is just as
the Revolution was winding down jacob
met and fell in love with Judy Myers of
New York who was in Philadelphia taking
refuge from the British occupation of
Manhattan when he asked for her hand in
marriage
Judy's father who I like to think of as
a sort of Jewish Paul Revere he was a
patriot and a very successful
silversmith he granted permission on the
condition that the couple not return as
Jacob had planned to any such
god-forsaken backwater as Virginia New
York's economy like much of the nations
in that time was a shambles however and
trade with Britain was suspended and
Jacob was really having a hard time
getting a foothold he kept thinking of
Virginia and the opportunities that he
had left behind and finally after some
years of you know not very successful
house holding the sold silversmiths
relented and the the couple moved
migrated first to Virginia and
ultimately to North Carolina in
Warrenton North Carolina a county seat
which lies in the state's eastern
plantation district Jacob opened a store
and some of you may be familiar with
that
opening of a general store as a as a
very common template for Jewish entry
into a new region and and that certainly
happened a great deal in the post-civil
war era Warrenton was tiny just two
hundred Souls half of whom were African
enslaved African Americans and by the
way the more turkeys did participate in
the slave system as soon as they could
afford to and that was part of their
assimilation into southern society the
more turkeys in Warrenton or the towns
only Jews the family grew steadily but
Jewett judy's health faltered and in
1796 she died after childbirth
Jacob remarried and his offspring
ultimately numbered 13 in 1807 the store
fell victim to the economic turmoil
surrounding Jefferson's embargo and in
1809 Jacobs career took a surprising
turn building on his intellectual bent
and growing a growing demand for female
education in the New Republic because
the idea was that if we're gonna have
these virtuous if we're gonna have this
free society we need to have super
virtuous citizens and those super
virtuous citizens are going to be
brought up for their early lives by
women and so we better educate the women
so that we can have these citizens that
will make our systems Republic
successful so he opened a boarding
school for girls this venture with
critical assistance from several
daughters and one of whom you'll be
hearing about later Caroline and also a
son prospered for a decade drawing
students from three states ten years
after it opened the school was sold for
ten thousand dollars which was a tidy
sum in 1819 and the family moved to a
farm outside of Richmond now years past
and during the time of Andrew Jackson's
presidency and I know everyone here
knows when that was 69 year old Jacob
made a pilgrimage to his birthplace for
decades had passed
he had walked the streets of his
childhood so he moved to the south and
he had not left since he'd gotten there
he visited the site of his former home
and he passed the school where Jacob and
his fellow students had put on denim
uniforms and taken up toy muskets to
parade the nation's founding fathers
into the city for the meeting of the
First Continental Congress at mikveh
Israel the the congregation had replaced
the modest temple he knew from his
childhood with a grand neo Egyptian
structure Jacob called on Isaac Leeser a
former Richmond resident and Jacobs
intellectual protege who was boldly
revitalizing Philadelphia's Jewry he was
probably the most independent most
important figure in Antebellum Jewish
leadership Jacob's warm reception among
Philadelphia's prominent Jews was
especially rewarding he was not rich but
he had established an acclaimed girls
Academy and retired respectively
becoming in the words of one
Philadelphia Jewish lady a venerable
gentleman more important perhaps Jews
who took their religion seriously
admired his scholarship for Jacob had
undergone a spiritual awakening in
Warrenton 20 years earlier back to the
revivals right after the school opened
in 1809 Warrenton North Carolina
experienced what was happening all over
this region in the early 19th century it
a revival cast began among the citizens
and that meant that there were these
meetings at night people were praying
people were experiencing religious
conversions and these were people who
were nominally Christian who had perhaps
not been very pious but they were
rededicating themselves to to their
faith Jacob went to a lot of these
meetings and he apparently went to them
with what he said later a mind little
trammeled with the faith in which he was
born now rumors started
this world that Jacob was going to
convert and this was a rather
uncomfortable thing for for the family
it wasn't clear that this was true and
and Jacob kind of sat on it for a while
until finally he said this is absolutely
not true and I'm not going to any more
meetings and in fact everything that I
have observed and and learned has
convinced me that I and I believe in the
religion of my forefathers so these
events had helped transform him into a
devout and much more active member of
the Jewish community and of course there
was no Jewish community in Warrenton but
there was a small one in Richmond and
when they moved to Richmond he became
very much a part of it so thus in later
life Jacob defended his faith against
proselytism from the outside and
reformed from within he mentored young
Jews trying to sustain ancient
traditions in the modern and sometimes
hostile and prejudiced world
Jacob correspond with Christians
directly about Judaism and protested the
anti-semitism inherent in the
proselytizing so common in those years
he also led the Richmond congregation he
delivered the dedication address and its
new sanctuary and over the course of two
decades he compiled a commentary on each
book of the New Testament drawing
attention to passages where it didn't
that did not accord with the Hebrew
prophecies about the Messiah and he
wrote a lengthy critique of efforts to
liberalize the form of worship at
Charleston's synagogue Beth Elohim which
which was where really the birthplace of
reformed Judaism so we see a picture of
a man who was perhaps not terribly
concerned with religion early in his
life moved to this small town and and
then experiences a revitalization of his
belief he and the form that that took
was really quite Orthodox he did not
support the kind of changes that we see
later in in the century for these
efforts Jews in Jacobs hometown hailed
him as a prophet in Israel
the words of the man that Philadelphia
Jews welcomed as a prophet were not
however always attended within his own
family and so anyone who's a parent can
begin to listen here during nearly the
same period jacob's daughter Caroline
Mordecai Plunkett took steps that
amounted to an outright rejection of his
beliefs
Caroline's intermarriage marriage to a
non Jew ten years earlier and she
married a man named Achilles Plunkett an
instructor at the Mordecai school who
had later purchased the Academy from the
family her intermarriage had given Jacob
pain but nothing could compare with the
shock he was about to receive no more
Turkey had married more happily than
gentle intense Caroline nor so
tragically she had fallen in love with
Achilles when she was quite a young
woman he'd come to teach at the school
he was an older man the family opposed
this love affair from the very beginning
they gave her all kinds of trouble there
were late night sessions convincing her
to stop seeing him to stop taking piano
lessons from him to stop taking art
lessons from him and this went on for
years and years without much impact
finally when the school was sold
Caroline was separated from Achilles the
family thought he just wasn't promising
enough in his career they knew all about
teachers and how how much upward
mobility they had and they also didn't
like that he was older and had had two
children of his own finally though
Caroline was so depressed that her
father relented and she and Achilles had
two blissful years of married life which
were also very hard-working years
because as a couple they were running
the school back in Warrenton now this is
the point where in my research it became
like checking in daily with General
Hospital or days of my lives because of
days of our lives because in the space
of two years Caroline who had finally
realized this dream of marrying Achilles
she had to she'd had two children two
sons
and first one fell ill and succumbed to
the disease two months later and Here I
am reading these letters one after the
other two months later another one fell
ill and also died soon after that
Achilles himself was taken from her and
she at the time was was carrying a third
child of his she gave birth to that
child and it was he died before he was a
year old it's you know almost impossible
for us to imagine a series of
bereavements like that I think alone and
in charge of the school Caroline refused
despite pleadings from her siblings
because it just wasn't proper for a
woman in her situation to be running a
business like this by herself she
refused there to respond to their
pleadings to come home she was a
fiercely independent person and she told
them that she just couldn't leave
Warrenton this was the site of all her
past joys for the next five years
Caroline taught school and to the extent
that her brother Moses's Rowley in-laws
would permit she kept his three elder
children who were orphans by this time
because Moses himself had died with her
as as boarding pupils but the family of
Moses his wife removed her nephews and
niece from her care they wanted them
home and depression stopped Caroline as
warrant ins economy declined neighbors
left for opportunities further south
including in Tennessee and she faced
increased competition from other
academies so this idea of female
education had caught on and there was
like one of these in every town and no
longer did the more turkeys have such a
such a corner on the market the world
seemed to be closing in eventually
Caroline took refuge in Wilmington North
Carolina near at near the home of her
sister Rachel and there she launched one
more school
mrs. Plunkett's seminary for young
ladies as it was advertised began
promising Leigh and when some of her
pupils families prepared to spend the
summer at the seashore which people who
could afford to and
did in those days because the malaria
was so so devastating in the town some
of Caroline's new friends put her up
there and supplied a classroom and in
this way her establishment continued
through the hot months with thirty five
scholars and this was so important to
Caroline because it ensured a continuing
stream of income which as I've said you
know contributed to her ability to
maintain her in financial independence
Caroline's teaching duties may have
remained steady but her life did not go
on as before that summer of 1832 she
announced her conversion to Christianity
Caroline's conversion did not come
suddenly she had studied the question
for over a year
neither her character nor the
circumstances permit Caroline's act to
be read as a bid for mere social
acceptance
however Caroline never consulted Jacob
before taking a step that her gentile
acquaintances in wilmington some of whom
were very much involved in the sort of
evangelical movement must have
celebrated not surprisingly her
announcement met with a different
reaction in richmond jacob railed at her
for giving him no opportunity to orally
encounter your doubts and meet your
arguments she had he said dealt him a
pang which time can never remove
caroline held fast refusing to give her
father any hope of reversing her action
and apparently willing to forfeit his
love if it came to that
just how tense things were is suggested
by the fact that there's quite a gap in
the family correspondence and i'm
talking about a family where i would
have you know letter letter letter every
month and there was there was a lacuna
here which suggests to me that these
letters were destroyed or separated at
some time if I ever become convinced I
am in error I will tell our dear parent
immediately Caroline promised another
sister but you know I cannot say I
disbelieve what I believe
not long afterward Caroline sought
refuge in LaGrange Tennessee in the
state's far eastern edge among old
warrant and friends who had opened a
female Academy there the wounds on both
sides would be long in healing and yet
Caroline's conversion was only the most
dramatic expression of the choices each
more Turkey faced when it came to
finding a meaningful place or expression
for Judaism in their lives to the
frustration of Jacob and of many parents
then and now religious belief is not
directly inherited and for me telling
this family's story has meant granting
the same respect to those who changed
their religious affiliation as to those
who sustained who sustained it or
awakened the one that they grew up with
and also to those who buffeted by the
forces around them never really
articulated what they felt about God and
so their people in this family fall
really on all parts of the spectrum when
it came to religious religious
expression and religious identity and I
think that that while I would never
claim that that is typical in of the
Jewish experience I think it is not
atypical of any family or of the
American experience in the sense that
religion really is something that people
have taken a very independent stand
about of course the fitnah of our
Constitution promises that sort of
freedom it is to be remembered though
that Caroline and her 12 siblings faced
these questions without the benefit of a
Jewish community of Jewish communal life
or education and these are matters that
later generations of American Jews have
taken much much more seriously and that
in the shadow of the 20th century and
the events that have that Jews have been
victimized by that no one cannot take
seriously but the morning key children
grew up in a different time they breathe
the hopeful spirit of freedom that their
revolutionary heir apparent
had carried with them into North
Carolina Jacob and Judy had instilled in
their offspring the dream of an
inclusive American identity and and of
inclusive American identity and the
opportunities that that brought and
they'd framed for themselves a happy
country as one daughter once wrote where
religious distinctions are scarcely
known and religion was just one part of
life after all for the more turkeys were
attempting to assimilate as Patriots and
southerners perhaps most fundamentally
they were trying to assimilate as
middle-class whites that they're passed
through this maze of identities was
challenged from within the family as
much as from without is perhaps also
quintessentially American the more
turkeys whose intelligence passion and
spirit pour from their papers challenged
us with the often uncomfortable freedom
at the core of American family life and
religious life and at an in the core of
American history itself thank you so
much
I have a critic yes they were German of
a German origin Jacob's father was named
Moses in the Earl and earlier Moses and
he was said to have been born in Bonn
Germany but he made a stopover in
England and then came from there to the
United States in the 1750s yes when they
moved down south
persecuted right one of the really
that's a great question the question is
how accepted were the more turkeys in
this in this region where there were so
few Jews a lot of people assume that
there was a lot of anti-semitic
prejudice in in the south and in America
during this time most historians and I
agree have found that this time was you
know by measures of anywhere else in the
world a very open period and accepting
period for most Jews that doesn't mean
that there weren't uncomfortable moments
there were for instance a couple of
times more turkey men proposed to women
who weren't Jewish and I don't know
exactly why they were rejected but but
at times they were other times they were
accepted the but there was not there was
not any kind of systematic prejudice to
which the the family was was subjected
so they were able to practice their
religion as they wished they were able
to practice their business as they wish
and they were accepted to the degree
that yes people came to their stores
they were invited to parties there's a
wonderful line and one of the girls
letters about sort of having to go to a
party where the you know the guts of a
cat were drawn across what was it with
the Horta the tails of the horse are
drawn across the guts of a cat and so
they were part of the social life of
this small town in a way that I think
would be surprising perhaps to to us now
on the other hand they always felt they
were different they've never felt
completely at home or completely
accepted and so there was an edge of
discomfort and partly it was because
they were kind of different they were
more educated than most of their
neighbors they valued education in a way
that America had
to start to do I would say they were
sort of at the cutting edge of that
values of middle-class valuing of family
life and education that came to be very
dominant later in the century but so
they did one of the ways they managed
that sense of difference was to do what
any family does when it's plagued by a
sense of being an outsider and that is
to develop myths about who they were and
one of those myths was that they were
smarter than people and those the people
they knew and that they were more
interesting and I can't really deny them
that they certainly lived up to their
own myth but like all myths they serve a
purpose and they don't always last
forever and so the dissolution of this
myth this covenant of who they were as
more Tukey's is also part of the story
it interesting the the commitment to the
south and particularly during the Civil
War and just commitment to slavery and
and to the south and the fact that
Alfred was really because he opted to to
resign from the US Army but chose not to
become a military figure in the
Confederacy I mean I just their
commitment to the South seems so much
stronger than I guess I expected them to
to be opposed to slavery or to be and
they were and I don't know I mean just
yeah I mean it's one of the things that
I think a lot of oh I'm sorry thank you
well one of the assumptions that some of
us bring to looking at a Jewish family
is liberalism because so many Jews have
played such an important and liberal
role in 20th century and even later 19th
century American life the the more
turkey family was liberal in many ways
actually but when it came to race they
were exactly in tune with their society
and I think it would be
rather unfair for us to expect anything
different than that as uncomfortable as
that fact is my forebears were living in
the same period they even met some of
the more turkeys at one point by
coincidence and I carry the same burden
this is this is our history yeah well I
am a historian and I started this
project and it took me about six or
seven years to read through the
manuscript documents because there were
simply so many so I had to cut off at
some point and I could have gone beyond
the Civil War I decided that that was a
good way to frame how this family had
formed itself and how the nation had
gone through a similar formative
crucible but there are many more turkeys
still among us and descendants not all
of whom carry that name and their their
name is not only on the historic house
in Raleigh but it's on fellowships at
Duke University because one of the
members of the family played a prominent
role in the university and you can also
read about them at a website about the
founding of Madera County California
where one of them went in the 1870s and
started a ranch which the family still
owns today after all these generations
question is whether Jacob and Caroline
ever reconciled this father-daughter
conflict that left them both so bruised
and and and hurt yes and no Jacob was
convinced by his other another of his
daughters Rachel to try to forgive
Caroline that that to hold you know hold
her in this sense
she felt she had been sort of exiled
really by the family and that even if
she stayed with other members of the
family she would sort of be turning them
against their father and poisoning their
those relationships so because that was
such a strong feeling of her as her
sister Rachel encouraged the father to
to you know relieve her somewhat and he
did write a letter to her in Tennessee
doing that and I think it made it helped
I don't think it completely succeeded
they did remain more in touch he wrote
to her he said please don't ever don't
ever bring this topic up again first of
all he said do write home do tell us of
your you know yourself and how things
are going for you whether your work is
successful and all that we do want to
know which I think was very reassuring
it to the degree that before that I
think she wasn't even sure he wanted to
hear about her at all and then later in
her life in the 1860s she ended up going
to Moby laughter Tennessee and and
teaching there and had quite an
independent and admirable life I think
really they're just very few women like
this who who'd struck out on their own
at of her class and she did come home to
Richmond at the time of the Civil War
and was brought back into the family
fold in a in a more full way though by
that time her father it was long long
dead another question
papers been preserved you know with
their particularly preserved in North
Carolina given all of the moves you know
to Richmond and everything else because
they weren't except for the boarding
house maybe they weren't a particularly
you know they didn't set up a major
tobacco companies or like some of the
other families right the question is how
are the papers preserved that that were
the basis for from my telling of this
story and it's a great question because
you know these things can seem so random
and I think they really are random to
certain degree we all should be
wondering how our lives and our eras
will be read and understood by
generations hence and I encourage you to
give that some thought because people
like me are totally dependent on people
like you but the more turkeys I have
references within their papers to them
reading over for instance there was a
family reunion in the early 1830s they
all got together in Richmond and they
brought out their old letters and they
sat around in the evenings and you know
people will be sewing someone would play
a piano for a while and they would sit
around the fire reminiscing about the
old days and for instance the days when
they ran the school in warrant and they
called themselves this happy band of
love and duty in those days and and and
so someone was keeping those had already
started keeping and collecting the
letters and from what I can tell that
the letters were passed down most of the
letters first of all were written by
women and the letters women were very
important in this family and so central
and I think they though some of those
women continued to hold them until - and
cast them down the generations to the
point in the 1940s there were people
going around North Carolina knocking on
doors asking people if they had any
papers in their attic and
was a famous guy who did this in North
Carolina with the wonderful name JG the
rule Hawk Hamilton and JG he thanked God
for JG he he he he roped him in so that
that's one collection but then there's
several more Alfred's papers are at the
Library of Congress for instance his
family kept all of his things and
they're in a beautiful collection there
so I was extraordinarily lucky and well
endowed with documents but I think it
part of it came from a sense within the
family that they were special and I feel
very grateful to them for having that
sense one more do you want it is in
trying to remember it is that the Hebrew
Union College and in Cincinnati in the
Jacob Rader Marcos archives and this is
this critique that Jacob wrote of the
books of the New Testament you know
which was a not a uncommon sort of angle
to take on these religious disputes
which was to say now look here and you
know Isaiah it says this but look in in
in you know the Matthew it says this
this doesn't fit together and I can't
remember the whether it's been
transcribed or not
Jacob's handwriting is extremely
difficult to read and so if it's
transcribed you could probably get a
nice photocopy from them if it's not I I
would say you better go to Cincinnati
documents and I guess you get used to it
but was that my I thought that's that
got a lot worse over these years thank
goodness for contact lenses or my
glasses would be like an inch thick but
but the women were taught very actually
almost
all the more turkeys had what was you
know considered then good handwriting
but but the women's was especially easy
to read it was more open but the thing
that got complicated was that they
filled their their papers so much yes
you can see how someone has turned this
on three sides and that's on the side
that the address was on so just around
the margins of the address cuz what you
would do is you have a big piece of
paper you fold it in half and then you
fold that and put the stamp on the
outside and so and then when times were
hard actually and they couldn't afford
paper especially during the Civil War
there are lots of letters in which they
and this is not uncommon at all in which
they wrote across the page this way and
then they turned it and wrote across
what they had just written at ninety
degrees this was extremely you know
tedious reading and you just but you
hate to think I can't skim it I might
miss that one reference to you know
slavery or that one reference to an
important emotional event in the family
and so I tried to plug through it yes
yeah another good question about slavery
I mean slavery was really one of the
most challenging things for me to write
about and one of the things that I feel
that historians often haven't done
terribly well and I don't think I've
succeeded in either really is to give a
sense of how slavery was integrated into
the daily lives of people like the
mordicus you know we were saying you're
talking about a system that was part of
their every waking hour practically
whether it was ordering somebody around
to do the laundry or wash something or
send a message to somebody whether it
was I mean these were people were living
in town mainly they weren't plantation
holders for the most part but or whether
it was you know helping you know in the
school days they had part one of the
duties of the slaves was to examine the
heads of each of the little girls for
lice they made sure they didn't you know
go through a major lice outbreak so I
mean these slavery was so embedded in
life and and yet they hardly said a
thing about it and that doesn't mean I
don't have any you know I do I I have a
whole list of names of slaves who are
referred to in the papers and I have you
know tax rolls that you know show me how
many slaves were working in the
household and their ages approximate
ages but as far as a really human face
on slavery they're just glimpses
glimpses that can be very revealing for
instance there was a slave who was in
the household of Rachel and in
Wilmington and she was the cook and
Rachel was very excited about her
because I think she was a good cook and
yet Rachel ended up calling her st.
Sophia they fell out over religion
actually in Sofia and I don't know
exactly why but Sophia one day told her
mistress that she just couldn't work for
someone who was Jew and and I don't know
if this might have had to do with
cooking practices possibly though there
is they did not keep kosher
no the but but you know possibly Sophia
was a very religious Christian and
wanted to go to meetings that Rachel
didn't you know see the need for her to
do there are lots of or maybe she just
you know was using it as an excuse I
mean there all kinds of possibilities
but whatever it was it was bad enough
that she was sold so so that that's a
glimpse into a there are other episodes
in the family's life where people taught
slaves to read there's a couple of
emancipation stories these are limited
there were some limited glimpses of
liberal more liberal views but on the
other hand when one sister wanted to
emancipate a slave she was dissuaded by
her brother who said oh you know if you
take that child to Philadelphia and set
it loose it will be in much much worse
worse shape than being a slave here
really if you want to take care of the
child and and protect it and give it a
good life it should stay with you
the 15th annual southern festival of
books is hosted by humanities Tennessee
visit TN - humanities org for more
information